good morning hicks tuesday you want to
know something wild about avocados you
know how when you open up an avocado
there's a toy inside just like a kinder
egg except it's always the same toy it's
a wooden ball well that turns out to be
a seed now you'll note that the avocado
seed is much much larger than say an
apple seed or a carrot seed or an acorn
which turns out to be because the
avocado tree co-evolved with all this
american megafauna which by the way is a
good name for a band here we need a
brief side note on the history of
mammals in the americas so until about
12 000 years ago there were all of these
huge animals in the americas like there
was a beaver that weighed almost 300
pounds there was the mastodon the
american lion the dire wolf turns out
not to have just been a thing from game
of thrones there were also these giant
armadillo looking things called
glyptotherium that weighed up to 2000
pounds in giant sloths that were 15 feet
tall and massive bears that may have had
to eat like 35 pounds of meat per day to
survive and all of these animals and
many more lived in the americas for over
a million years before they all went
extinct along with many other large
mammal species about 12 000 years ago at
the end of the pleistocene epic why did
they go extinct that is a much debated
question and i am not looking to get
into any fights with paleobiologists
some argue that climate change was the
primary factor some argue that human
behavior including over hunting may have
contributed to the extinctions but at
any rate back in those days you saw a
lot more seeds the size of avocado seeds
and this makes sense right because it
was not a big deal for a glyptotherium
or a giant sloth to eat an avocado and
poop out the seed because they were huge
animals with correspondingly huge
poopholes this was great for everyone
involved because the animal would get
some fats and vitamins from the avocado
and then walk for a while before pooping
which would allow the avocado to spread
and give it a bit of fertilizer to start
its life with but then like 12 000 years
ago this seed dispersal strategy went
away with the extinction of all of these
large animals and suddenly all the
squirrels were like i mean i'm not gonna
poop out that avocado so many of these
large seeded trees declined or went
extinct with the major exception of the
avocado why two reasons first avocado
trees live for a really long time like
they can live for over 400 years so they
had a long runway to try to figure out
how to live without giant mammals but
probably the biggest factor was humans
there's evidence that humans were
consuming avocados nine or ten thousand
years ago but we may have been trading
and cultivating them even before that
and so via humans the avocado spread
from its home in what is now central
mexico to south america and the
caribbean and eventually the world i
find it quite encouraging to consider
that humans living all that time ago did
us this huge huge favor by preserving
the avocado but it's also a reminder
that the choices we make as humans can
reverberate through history not just for
like dozens of years but for tens of
thousands because like strangest of all
contemporary humans have begun to try to
find ways to make avocado pits smaller
so that we can have more avocado in our
avocados and if they succeed it's
possible that we could arrive at a time
when avocado seeds are small enough that
they could be pooped out by say a
raccoon
meaning that potentially the avocado
tree could survive the age of humans
just as it survived the pleistocene not
in spite of humans but because of us we
are not merely a force of destruction in
this world and we certainly don't have
to be merely a force of destruction and
the avocado is a reminder of that
hank i'll see you on friday